can i ask you about uh actually one
person i'm getting a little serious for
a minute but i spoke to both candice
cameron and jody sweden this week about
bob how are you feeling about the loss
horrible horrible there is no words to
describe how horrible i feel about
uh you know the loss of
a good friend and he was everybody's
good friend i don't i can't imagine
anybody that was more beloved than bob
saget by so many people in so many walks
of life and the outpouring has just been
crazy and well deserved and you know
it's just unfathomable that you know i
can't pick up a phone and call that guy
when i talk to candace and jody they're
like i'm going back i'm looking at the
text are there any moments you're sort
of remembering and hanging on to in in
memory of bob well we all do that i
think you go back and i don't think we
ever got a text that didn't end with i
love you you know which is
and they're not just words from him you
really felt like he connected with
everybody he's not just there are people
you know and people you work with and
people you talk to and then there's a a
little special few that you connect with
and he connected with so many he is just
goodness i love that thank you thank you
for saying that
we do have some other great comedians
here mr kevin hart is here are you going
to go find him and be able to have a
laugh with him today i'm actually here
to do his show what is it like to do a
kevin hart show i think it's going to be
i'm going to be honest with you i am a
professionally uh judge of talent and
i've been watching kevin he's gonna that
kid's gonna make it
we can only help yeah okay thank you
[Music]